oh this is older than me
um
Since I no longer carry life insurance
worth more than me
in a lot of respects
and you know what is a we can ask the
same thing with with this as we can with
this
same final pause right to make music
strings are themselves a metal of some
sort although you could do it with like
fishing line if you want to be really
hillbilly about it plastic right some
plastic pegs which I guess probably back
in 1965 are kind of state of the art you
know
um anything else we're missing oh
whatever this is made of so that's the
material pause what's the formal cause
this is together in a very
different would this be a banjo if it
had a different um
shape to adhere
who made this
um the Vega company